we're looking at wanting to pay our
house off we don't have any other debt
and how do people do that like is it
okay to just set aside the money and
then pay it off in one month sum or what
is what's the ramsy weers or
recommendation every month send as much
towards the house payment as you can
send and what happens is it lowers your
balance so the next month more of your
regular payment will go towards
principal then in then it would have if
you hadn't let's say you sent $10,000
okay well you no longer have to pay
interest on that $110,000 so the in the
monthly interest on that
$10,000 less will be low I mean on the
balance will be lower than uh than it
was by $10,000